[Music]
have you been touring around a lot I
haven't really seen you around LA uh
yeah no I haven't been doing a lot of
stand-up recently I just did my special
so it's out there so I'll probably wait
a while before I put something else
understandable how I wanted to talk
about like weird Road stories because I
know you do tour a lot and uh III
replaced pitbull at the University of
Southern Florida like an outdoor concert
if you don't know who pit bull is pimple
is like is mr. worldwide and he's he's a
hip-hop artist slash villain from Grand
Theft Auto hey Wayne
so it's the University of Southern
Florida and big hip-hop fans of the
school it's a big outdoor concert and I
got the call like II can you fight on a
folder and replace pitbull for the show
oh you knew you knew going in yeah okay
I thought maybe you got there and
they're like by the way they thought it
was the hey gotta be pitiful and I know
know what [ __ ] because I should have
known like if you're asking for pitbull
and then you get to me 50 other people
passed and between that you know it's
not like we weren't a pitbull get me
Burnham sorry but it was more money than
I've ever gotten for a show this is a
big outdoor like 3,000 people out in the
carnival and I flew down there the night
of and I got off the plane and I was
reading tweets that said this Bo Burnham
kids replacing our beloved mr. worldwide
and literally literally though I'm we're
gonna let's go in throw bottles at them
let's go throw bottles at his head when
we get there and money retweets it
that'd be nice if it was Dasani bottles
I'd feel fine with it like a bit like
economic caps you think they're honor
but so I'm backstage like dry-heaving I
was nervous I've ever been I wore a
t-shirt point of I were like a t-shirt
of the school like really suck up to
them yeah they came over when I wrote a
song cuz people have broken his hand so
I wrote a song to sort of open it making
fun of people for breaking his hand
sticking with it this is like a thing to
like really into your
myself to them so I think it's online
pirated somewhere really but I got
through it and apparently there is a
tiny Venn diagram between you have bit
pitbull fans and my fans and some of
them are there it was okay here do you
do yeah yeah and I'm Bob it's alright I
mean I'll never really be scared of a
show again because yeah I really knew
what it was like to fear for my head my
life I'm glad he made it okay thanks
buddy hi the reason I asked if you knew
ahead of time as I did at college and it
was supposed to be in Aziz Ansari show
yeah and they didn't tell them that it
was me so I came out and it was thrown
by like the Asian Student Union so is
all Indian kids and they went
ladies and gentleman Aziz is not here
and audibly they went what and then just
a snowstorm of a man who an unsaved and
was like
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay wait very talented desert dog of
course I love his ease this is gonna
sound great
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Music]